Donald Trump has lost his battle in the
government shutdown border wall
so-called crisis I guess we can't really
say yet whether Donald Trump has won or
lost the war on this issue but this one
battle is one where that has seen Donald
Trump go down in flames
Trump has agreed to reopen the
government without one single penny for
his silly border wall and he has opened
government with the same deal that
Senate Republicans passed in December
before of we saw any of this nonsense
even get going
we saw airports slowing down to nearly a
halt in some cases federal workers in
such dire financial straits that some of
them ended up having to go to food
pantries in order to feed their families
35 or however many days it was in the
end and Donald Trump achieved nothing
he's back at square one with possibly
the exact same situation facing him in
three weeks because after this longest
shut down in history this is just a
stopgap measure this is something that
Trump has said if he doesn't get a deal
he likes by February 15th he will shut
it down again and then he says he likely
will declare a national emergency to
commandeer funding from the military for
the border wall that would be the crisis
there is no actual immigration crisis
Trump using this to justify a national
emergency and take money from the
military actually would be the crisis
and one of the biggest problems with
this whole strategy is that other than
ignorant low information Trumpets nobody
believes that undocumented immigration
is a crisis even conservatives who want
a wall in general understand it's not an
acute crisis and shutting down
government over this is a mistake and
forget about the fact for a second that
undocumented immigration has been
diminishing as a problem for a decade or
longer even since Trump took office
immigration numbers have been improving
if this is a crisis today then it was a
way bigger crisis when Donald Trump was
inaugurated and he had both the House
and the Senate but he didn't do anything
about it then why did Trump wait until
now it's
say that he now needs border wall
funding or he's shutting down the
government oh right
Democrats took over control of the house
so in a total major loss trump approval
is down Trump got no money for the wall
Trump is still not getting his State of
the Union speech tomorrow as far as we
currently know he and Nancy Pelosi are
going to need to agree on a new date on
which they will be doing that and Trump
has endangered his obviously ridiculous
status as an alpha male negotiator who
gets deals done because this is the
opposite of how to negotiate huge
drastic actions with massive political
risk end up getting Trump no closer to
what he wants which in this case is
money for the wall and the biggest
damage that Trump a have done is to
himself here it's making it more likely
that he will have a serious primary
challenger in 2020 a few close
associates of Trump are now saying that
not only has all of this shutdown stuff
taken away time and energy from Trump
actually starting to get going on his
plan to get himself reelected in 2020
they are saying that the shutdown plus
the recent indictment of Roger stone
that all of this stuff have Trump's
aides thinking it is more and more
likely that there's going to be a
serious Republican primary fight which
would be awesome that that would be a
fantastic thing and I'm getting tweets
all weekend I was getting tweets from
Trump is saying just wait to see how
Trump is going to win this thing in
three weeks when February 15th comes
around and the stop-gap of three weeks
ends
all right let's wait and see what
happens I've seen no evidence so far
that Trump is capable of the kind of
long-term thinking that would be
required for such a plan but we'll see
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman I want to
hear from you about this what do you
think about how this entire thing went
down and ultimately ended and follow the
show on twitter at david pakman show as
well much more to talk about glad you're
with us on this Monday quick break and
back with more after this one of the
day's sponsors is privacy calm slash
Pakman which is a free service that I
myself you
really useful in many different ways
takes just a few seconds to link your
debit card to privacy calm then you can
create virtual credit cards that are
linked directly to your bank account and
you use those virtual credit card
numbers to buy things online which
protects your actual debit card so that
it's not spread all over the Internet
and one of the best things about it is
how their mobile app and browser
extensions for Chrome and Firefox make
it really easy to use let's say for
example that I'm signing up for a david
pakman show membership in the credit
card number field I already see the
privacy comm icon I just click it choose
which of my virtual credit cards I want
to use and the credit card number
expiration date and security code are
automatically entered I can put in any
zip code I want and I'm done and if you
try to use my credit card number that
you just saw on the screen it doesn't
matter because I've already deleted that
virtual card and that's the beauty of
privacy comm there are a ton of
advantages to using a free service like
this for example you can sign up for as
many free trials as you want then just
delete the virtual credit card you used
and never worry about getting charged
for it it protects you from getting
hacked it protects you when companies
are hacked which happens all the time it
is all completely free all you have to
do is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
they're giving everyone in our audience
$5 towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link